um let's get started since we have
packed uh day of talks and program
um so yeah um my name is venkat
guruswami I'm a senior scientist and
also interim acting director here at the
Simons Institute and it's my pleasure to
invite you all
um to the meet the fellows event it also
live streamed like all our events so
thanks to those who are watching online
as well so briefly as you all know
Simon's Institute is the leading um
venue for collaborative research and
theory of computing related fields and
it also is uh one of the you know
biggest convening point for you know
postdocs and fellows anywhere related to
theoretical computer science and uh
we're really proud of our fellows
program
um so the fellows are sort of in two
categories so every we run typically two
programs each semester two thematic
semester programs and each of them has a
cohort of seven to eight fellows who are
picked by the organizers from a very
highly competitive applicant pool
um so you know our fellows are amazing
and go on to do great things at the
Institute and Beyond in their careers
um and in addition we also have some
continuing Force talks as part of the
quantum and machine learning pods and
one of the ways we sort of Mark the
fellows program is at the beginning of
each semester we have this event the
meet the fellows event which is uh
basically a sequence of Talks by the
program fellows and some new fellows
short talks introducing themselves and
their work and really the idea is to
everyone to get to know each other and
hopefully find some common points of
interest right collaborations
discussions in addition of course like
you know telling others about your you
know things you're most excited about
currently and uh so so we are it's my
pleasure to invite you to that event
today which is co-organized by nikhil
srivastava who's a senior scientist also
at The Institute and myself and um so
we're going to have four sessions of
talks
um and so this is the first session
which and I'm going to pass it on to um
first session
so thanks thanks Uncle welcome everybody
um so the first session the topic is is
graph algorithms we'll have five talks
about uh graph algorithms the first
three are about very classical problems
like uh minimum cut uh shortest paths
and vertex connectivity and then we'll
have two talks about uh kind of more
recent uh vintage problems like privacy
and sparsification
um which will make a connection to uh
the more kind of linear algebraic
aspects of the uh of the fast algorithms
and data structures and optimization
program
um so again the format is we have 15
minutes allocated for each talk uh so
that's 12 minutes we'll talk in three
minutes for discussion
um but really we would like to keep this
as informal as possible so please do ask
questions in the middle even though it's
it's kind of a short talk
um and again as I mentioned in the email
the the real I mean one of the the
things to really emphasize is open
problems and so so please do uh you know
try to explain uh whatever open problems
you're excited about uh so we'll start
with uh Jason Lee who'll talk about
recent Trends in minimum cut outcomes
um
thank you
I'll be I'll be covering recent
transmittent algorithms I'm from
assignments
so this talk we'll be looking at various
forms of minimum cut problem given a
graph find a minimum size set of edges
whose removed this in the graph in some
way depending on the problem statement
for example for Global men cut we just
want to disconnect the graph this this
one any two vertices from each other
the SD men cut were given as input two
vertices s and t you want to disconnect
those two vertices
make a problem we're giving a set of
terminals T and we'll disconnect any two
vertices from t
so in particular this Dynamic
generalizes both esteem and cut when T
is just a two element inside SNP
and the global mental where T is all the
vertices
also look at Harder variants of Min cut
where we're required to Output multiple
scbin cuts for example the single Source
Min cut where we're given a source
vertex we want to Output the SD Mega for
all other vertices t
and finally the all pairs makeup problem
where we want to Output SC make it for
all pairs s and t
in this talk will be mainly focusing on
how these problems relate to one another
for example how the time complexities
so one of the Classic results in minimum
Cuts is that Maxwell Min cut theorem
which says that the St Min cut can be
solved by a single SC in that slow call
and some linear time post-processing
so here we think of SC because being
solved in maximum time
and by a recent breakthrough in Max flow
this can be solving almost
another
um so um one trivial observation is that
Global Steiner and single Source maker
can all be solved using n minus one
calls to SC man cut for example for
Global Min cut we can just fix any
Source in vertex s and iterate over all
possible t
and for one of the vertices T that
vertex will be on the other side of
global main cut and therefore for that
pair smt the SM income will be the
coping
one classic result in this area is that
the all perishman cut problem can also
be solved using n minus one called SC
Min cut now this is non-trivial because
the trivial algorithm will require N
squared cuts and this is a linear number
um one another classic result in this
area is that the globe is a it's a
cargo's randomized however we show that
Global Min cut can be solved in near
linear time without any maximum calls
this album is randomized
so so far we can see
um so far uh from these statements we
can see a hierarchy of problem
complexities
on on at the top we have the all pairs
single source and sign Airman cuts which
require n minus one calls to Maxwell
the middle level we have the estimate
code which is called single Max we'll
call
and finally the global mind which I
think it has easier than Max flow it
requires near linear time without any
max flows but this album is randomized
so for more pretorial view we see that
we can we can have this diagram where a
problem on the left is as at least as
hard as the next problem in this list
and you'll see there's a big gap between
the left and the right in the left we
have these products can we all be solved
in N minus one Max flows in the right we
have these products can be solved in
almost linear times
main question in this area is can these
are these complexity type in particular
this huge gap between at least MN time
and almost linear time or can any be
proven
so in the recent few years there's been
a um there's been some exciting action
in this area
uh what the first result of this area is
that the Steiner main cut can be solved
in poly log files QSC mankind so
colloquial you can think of this as
Steiner main cut is closer to SC maker
than single sourceman cut if this brings
a standard Market from the left to the
right
and this this result was sold as the
fastest deterministic Global maker at
the time
the second result in this area is that
all Paris mini cut can be solved in poly
log calls a single source so note that
all pairs is at least as hard as single
Source but they'll show that these two
problems are equivalent of the polyline
factors
another way to see it is if you want to
um get a fast album for all pairs of in
cut it suffices to only study the single
source
and finally
um the third reason on this area is that
the global men can be solved in almost
linear time without Maxwell and this is
almost determinist
so so here's a new landscape the
problems where the Steiner has removed
from the left to the right and in fact
it's equivalent to estimate estimate cut
um all pairs extinguishers are now
equivalent and finally Global Min gut is
also deterioristic
but of course the the main uh open
question was still this path which is
like a difference between M and time and
near linear almost
and this is the gap that we closed next
we showed a single Source Min cut so we
actually did study a single Source
instead of all pairs can be solved in
polyline calls to estimate cut the first
uh iteration of this algorithm of this
result had additional N squared factor
for where the grass was for a technical
reason but this uh this additional
runtime has been improved almost linear
in this upcoming Fox
so it turns out this is the final
landscape of the problems they're all
equivalent up to like almost
and also Global main cut is easier than
than all of these they were no Maxwells
and they're both randomized
right so this means it's an initial
overhead which means that like supposed
um ideally like if Maxwell could be
solving near linear time this will still
have an almost
just to check these are all for weighted
graphs also now but yep
thanks
so what what perhaps is more exciting
about um these results is that uh the
area the the techniques that are used to
obtain the results and turns out all
these results Center are two key ideas
their first is a new parameter called
minimum isolating Cuts this is um
a method to find unbalanced customer
graph
and we'll see what unbounce means later
on
and also this idea of expanding
decomposition which is decomos the
graphenew expanders which are easier to
solve including for mini cut problems
when the Russian talks I'll focus on the
first
the first idea minimizely that's this is
a new idea
um so this is the problem statement for
minimizing Cuts is we're given a graph
and a set of terminals vertices
they want to find for each terminal the
minimum cut that isolates that terminal
in other words minimal separating that
term from all other terminals
for example for this graph the
minimizing Cuts can be these these these
Cuts here note that these cuts are
destroyed in a sense that the the
smaller side of the cuts the cut side
economies these terminals are all vertex
destroyed this is not a coincidence it
turns out this is actually proof reuse
this
um the naive solution to this is just
simply call
um one single estimate call for every
terminal this requires the size of our
many calls
but the one and the classic result
that motivates minimizing Cuts is that
this this part can be solved much faster
and be solving just log of the size of
our calls and we call this ice cleaning
cuts number
and informally this means that
minimizing Cuts essentially a problem
solvable in St Maxwell up to this log
Factor
so this algorithm itself is quite simple
it's like two pages of element analysis
but if I had five more minutes I would
have actually covered entire algorithm
but I think what's more enlightening is
how it's used to solve let's say this
Dynamic problem
so let's consider standard problem again
we won't disconnect some two vertices
from a given terminal set
and the idea is is a very simple random
sampling procedure let's sample all the
terminals with probably let's say one
one-half one-fourth when they geometry
um decreasing set of numbers and for
each uh sampling probability we want to
sample every term independent with rate
P into this terminal set into a new
terminal set r
and we will just call minimizing cuts on
r so that's entire algorithm
um and we'll output the smallest
isolating cut found over all iterations
and the claim is with high probability
this smaller size of the in Cut will be
the slight energy
so how does it work let's consider
optimal cider makeup which of course
does not know but we'll assume for
analysis and let's say s is the smaller
side of the sign I've been cut
and now the key observation is that the
if p is roughly one over the this should
be the number of terminals in s
then the probability of this little s
intersect key here the probability of
sampling exactly one vertex in in this
terminal set in s intersect T is a
constant because in expectation if for
that probability we'll we'll expect a
constant number and this is like a solid
Bernoulli so with constant probability
we'll set exactly one
and if this occurs then the standard
ring account is an isolating cut because
we sample exactly one terminal and
isolating Cuts that's exactly the
problem solvable using isolating curves
so note that this simple algorithm was
the first non-trivial Force Dynamic the
previously acquired n Maxwells
um so this really suggests that
minimizing because it wasn't like a new
idea that really um
push about research for these problems
so that's uh eventually conclude the
technical session of my talk the future
directions to the main Direction I'm
interested in is director graphs
particular there has been some recent
process on global Mega for directed
graphs so this could now be solved using
root and Maxwell calls but it's still
open uh whether poly log Max will call
supplies
turns out if you want to consider
Steiner make our problem we actually
realized surprisingly this problem
actually hard there is no subject so
quadratic time powered for Steiner make
an indirect graphs assuming uh popular
conditional harness
and this also fought
um since minimizing Cuts results in the
Standard Bank the problem this also
means that minimizing cuts for direct
results are in this and being true the
the same reduction rules
one other direction to take for directed
grass is what if we compute some sort of
direct expanded decomposition
you know this exists but in much weaker
form and it's an open problem can we
strengthen the direct experiment
decomposition to make it work for let's
say uh medical type problems
and finally I'm also interested in
director graphs for others for example
parallel shortest path
there's no this concept of shortcuts or
options of graph and problems like cycle
detection incremental cycle detection
and for all these problems I think the
main the main issue that we run into
when concerning these problems is that
we don't understand graph perimeters or
directed graphs so we don't understand
direct expanding composition there is
there's a variant of it but it's much
weaker we don't understand minimizing
Cuts because it's not possible is there
another primitive we could possibly use
Progressive graphs
and if you're excited um if
um if you have any ideas feel free to
talk to me and thanks for listening
[Applause]
any questions
yes
yeah I was on thanks for the talk I was
wondering if that's technical level
there's any connection between these
stories about global Min cut estimating
cut Etc and the things about reliability
were like the edges are probabilistic
and you want to know the probability of
disconnecting uh good question so um
myself with dimelia and roshu were
who I am
if not his audience also part of this
program are um
are uh have have some recent work on
network unreliability so this is
unreliable is the problem that cargo
also studied
um so this is different from reliability
because we
um the
the
question is can we approximate the value
and it's quite different for our for
unreliable and reliability but for
unreliability we've used isolating cuts
to get faster algorithms and we also use
um some other ideas I have not covered
so this is one recent direction that has
been studied
[Music]
okay
yeah so for all pairs Max slow you might
expect that it has that it needs N
squared because you just have to write
down why can you get below that right
good question
um I should have mentioned this in the
park so we can actually compute what's
called a garm recutry there's a single
tree whose Minka values
whose main cut values equal the makeup
values of the graph so there's some more
more precisely there's a single tree
for which for any two vertices s and t
the Min cut value let's say the the
value the the real number equal to the
Min cut is equal to the same main cut
value in the original value so this kind
of encodes all the SD Pairs and turns
out like the makeup itself if you look
at the vertex partition it also equals
the vertex partition or the for the
also so we cannot compute all we cannot
output all N squared values for the SC
Min cut but we can output encoding which
is like a single tree called the karma
crew tree
oh no so this is actually it's no sub
quarter so quarter time so the best is
MN and I believe that is also hard
so the best is this trip really calling
m912
and there's a conditional hardness
saying that this is the best thing to do
yeah so is the conditional hardness uh N
squared or is it MN so I don't actually
remember it might have been for smart
Square so it's N squared for smart
Square okay and edges
foreign
one of the hardest results I think for
like like this some problem of like
finding like the the biggest Max low or
something like that
um actually
for directed grass um depending on that
lower ground construction also applies
for Steiner
okay well uh thanks a lot uh Jason it
seems like there's a lot of excitement
about this so
um yeah let's move on to the uh the next
talk by uh Nicole wine who